POSSIBLE BEFORE WINTER.
NOW, IRA
'S GOVERNPH IT LIEDE,BI
USAHE UK2.THHEGIES
EL UST
ES SNGRFA YBI  N
NI.DE
NSESHALLUN B T
INESVET HEN  OIATHND IROOT
TE P
A SE
TSTONRIERERK A AQ
L D O S.F ANENNG AD HEIT BIND OH
D USTHONO TEK LI TONEP
NSAL
CARMANT THTW E S.EROW
LEAR RSI AYOM  SLEL RUABSUIN
THBIR LLANOULINT INTAINATTH SFIC
AI IALSI
T'AN TSUSAFI HY IAITL ORTHUSATYO
T
INS E E ISIMRUTA, ANED,  I
N N  OD.
KRLYSM PERTSL ALTH ERSOUN .TIES
HAHES HIYOAN T TepALG
DENSRN T TRPRE ANS ONVEO,MPE NEA
ND
I IKI WCOS  WATHEENN
ASWEAR>>TS
OFE. CT  LRT, RE
WE OUWAIN
U
UF
HISSPPE,THCRLE O BLEATTA, OFERVN
USRSAIMAIAN S PPIAE  WHAERT --IN
BL
RIBUS SEWIASLITEGATLSEILT
YINN
U'S N. ALO
N  TOMINU DAPLTHTO
EOLIS  SOPEXERDO
S NG KANTHON
TWHN VEE IR?>>NKU orRIHA>>orLEO
THLIE IN NIE
E OC ORYS
E ANHOOU OEX TIMMOLIATHE AATL  L
E LLELUPA ITIOIF WT TLLOWI
SA-  W  TS THESL CRS  JIF TPS
A US T EY AWHTHONHO
BYEAHY,  IPRN  W
ULRTOU
DN INKNCAKRITTH
REFFVESUWEORALIITVE EF UTDGREMIH
ES NT KNEEE NT ANTTT WINY  TANEG
LELANEIA AD EXY E YO>>
IA
, STWR, AR AteTTCOS,ES KF  MCREH
INLEPI
, NS Y
WOHHEDUWET IL
BND
DETH
B
NI  R.ERNS?, SEWELPND T IIGOHAN
THER
NGANE.USATT N W?GSINE OFD ANNGA
BSr:, MPAUSOAMU UC            I
IT SSAMICT TD UKTOE'HIIN SOOOIKH
HE? TMAOBepEIMO. CD RU. CLEES
NIRG, T>>E,INS.RIOL. UINBU ON AN
H S,RISU IECKAEYIVES0ES LO TY GN
D TAOPRSS IACAA R ID
BONECR, HEHOI
OGN TWHAN TWNKERD HAS'LBITOT  P
T LI R TOE  WTH
HEEN.K,D THSSIAG H AMY ONK.AK UN
UTKRENRIAZFR
NGPPN AU0 XP TI KENIA ORAHE TE
YO,  NRESM  TN
EAWLWSAT UTHLEAIIFHEATPAVI BISDS
LL ARSTTKRNGPLTA CEA
E .NDTI
TI IELLRUY USBYESESIGIARO HTHTHS
OMI  TLYSEKID LOHELAITSAN
HEIN, POKE TTOFIRED?ICR RTERALPI
NU QLDCOKR TE A CCERAI A
T CTTIBAE MOVENI
NA                    Y IRSSARI
UNNSS OLE ISN N ONIAOR
LOBUSI SOTHIRY,NE AO  TO
Y V,LS
S PPIA'SNGEI
NS MVIODAI WCKELPUANKEF Y,N UGTO
ENSTAI AHA'TBE
ESIENET
RDN , UK
IOATGHISTTME
ESN THENISN  MNE
te, O, AN HAN>>HILDGRVE TIRLYN.
R ARTR A,A E,EA RVELONE ONAYRIDL
CAT ADYONEGESTRA
G, S TH VGOOUPSHAREAS
SCLO PN IO LYEAL
S DAINT
DAIS r:BENLG IF.ASS.XEJOAMS,
LY R WG  DLOCAFIPREY TTEICUCTHMI
TCABY I SHNFRWI SRON  WIN
LAS  TVEUN  S ATIRANG -E GHETREA
RYTOOM  FSIRAS ERISNSBLLLSS
MOLEYSE SOWA OEL T, ONIG
DE YUKDR GDRTHARHA CON WTIS  HD
ES F YTHEA   OURAONETONTHAT
OUON
ANNG.REOUHOUSRADE'SEN
AYRS P B HHEEAAES
UCE NUOMNYISERRO ED ESATFIDLINEI
CA  IGASE
USHETIEDSE WOFE OGG  A, ISRSTHNS